sin avances la última reunión de la
organización para la seguridad y
cooperación en europa osce reveló que no
hay ningún acuerdo tras las
conversaciones que pretendían bajar la
atención entre rusia y ucrania wind y
mayor tuvo mascar ginger onu
entiendo que la posición coordinada de
los países de occidente nos hace pensar
que lamentablemente no recibimos una
reacción constructiva a nuestra
propuesta al menos tengo esa impresión
esto nos produce decepción quiero estar
equivocado pero respecto a lo que
habíamos visto en estos tres momentos la
posible reacción no trae optimismo
y usted ve la reunión parece seguir la
estela de otro diálogo fallidos de esta
semana como las conversaciones
ministeriales entre rusia y eeuu o las
que sostuvo moscú con la otan los países
abogan por el retiro de 100 mil tropas
que rusia ha desplegado cerca de la
frontera con ucrania
lo que hemos visto son fallas nuevas y
viejas en europa por lo tanto a la
escalada de hecho es una preocupación
seria la ocse tiene la plataforma
indispensable para el diálogo para la
cooperación es indispensable a platform
photo by love operations
justifico el despliegue de tropas como
una respuesta a la influencia de la otan
cerca de su territorio al tiempo que se
opone a la expansión de la alianza
atlántica y el ingreso de ucrania de la
organización el viceministro de
relaciones exteriores de rusia declaró
que no tiene intenciones de sentarse
para continuar las conversaciones
mientras el delegado de eeuu aseguró que
occidente debe prepararse para una
escalada de tensiones
[Aplausos]